a todas las víctimas choque de poderes
en Colombia los protagonistas Gustavo
Petro el primer presidente de izquierdas
del país y Francisco Barbosa fiscal
general de la nación elegido en la
administración de la expresidente Iván
Duque Petro pidió explicaciones esta
semana al ministerio público por
supuestamente haber archivado
investigaciones sobre masacres cometidas
por el clan del Golfo una Poderosa Banda
criminal del país desde su gira en
Europa Petro dijo ser el jefe del fiscal
y posteriormente reafirmó esas
declaraciones
el jefe del ministerio público acusó al
mandatario de estar cambiándose el traje
de demócrata por el de dictador Barbosa
dio a conocer que recurrirá a la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos y que sus familias saldrá del
país por razones de seguridad es una
advertencia
que le hace al fiscal general de
Colombia
de que si no obedezco
seguramente tendré consecuencias la
guerra verbal desató todo tipo de
reacciones políticas y un debate sobre
las potestades del presidente aclaradas
por expertos jefe de estado no lo hace
jefe de las ramas del poder público que
integran la organización Estatal es un
tema totalmente distinto la fiscalía
general de la nación pertenece a la rama
judicial de Colombia que es un poder
absolutomente independiente del
Ejecutivo en este caso El Ejecutivo
nacional liderado por el señor
presidente de la república la Corte
Suprema acusó al presidente de generar
inestabilidad institucional y
malinterpretar la Constitución no es el
primer choque entre Petro y Barbosa sus
discrepancias han girado sobre todo en
torno a la política de paz Total que
defiende Petro y a la que Barbosa le ha
presentado reparos por las peticiones
para levantar órdenes de captura contra
jefes de organizaciones narcotraficantes